que ce soit en mauritanie où passent
aujourd'hui le dakar au mali où nous
étions à l'instant les musulmans du
monde entier sont en pleine période de
ramadan
un milliard de personnes sur terre
pratique ce carême qui durera moins qui
est interrompue chaque soir par un
véritable repas de fête
nous allons partir au maroc découvrir
avec le chef de cuisine d'un grand
palace commente on prépare ce repas
reportage jean jacques dufour bruno
girodon à marrakech
le chef c'est lui enfin dix ans plus tôt
histoire de ne pas mettre le souk dans
la royauté que c'est le chef des
cuisines de l'un des plus beaux palaces
du monde
la mamounia sous ses ordres 90 personnes
qu'il mène comme les chinois à la
baguette c'est une figure de style parce
qu'ici la spécialité s'est pas vraiment
le canard laqué de toute façon canard ou
tajine en période de ramadan
pas question de goûter avant le coucher
du soleil en vue de manger mais en
résistant même à l'ap un patient et
aussi at elle écrit en français ça va
être dur pour vous quand on est bien peu
dur mais après les premiers jours où
garder ça va tout seul on s'habitue à
tout même au supplice de tantale et les
pigeons brisé clé pour la bastille à un
peu d'huile la coriandre fraîche la
cannelle en bois
du safran quand on parle des pis le
poids des mots ne vaut vraiment pas le
choc des photos
jambes du coeur que moi c'est du bâton
de cannelle à la cannelle en poudre
ce document porte et ça c'est quoi cette
vie pistils de safran
dites-leur si naturel
elle donne un colorant semé nouveau si
délicieuse délicieux à condition d'avoir
le doigté mélanger des épices et un truc
d'artistes dans un seul plat où trouver
5 à 6 et pistes différentes
donc si vous mettez une hippie sans plus
il cache le la saveur de l'autre et donc
vous l'avez vous n'avez pas un très bon
résultat tout le monde n'en passant pas
pour le salé une séquence douceur
s'impose c'est pas bon pour le régime un
pardon c'est pas bon pour le régime du
sein mais s'est réservée pour les
gourmets elle entend tous les jours on a
envie de manger mais après je vous
remets aux gourmands une chose est sûre
pour un boulanger ramadan ce pain béni
pour les bouchers aussi d'ailleurs car
ne l'oublions pas c'est 30 jours de
jeunes c'est l'occasion de faire la fête
et même une grande fête très caloriques
un seul exemple la soupe de rupture du
jeûne la hrira oignons coriandre voix
chiches lentilles des d'oignons et bien
à rire à ses 380 calories par lou il
faut pas on a deux ou trois voiles à la
fois un bonne nuit ça suffit largement
et devrait trouver comment la soupe de
votre femme est bonne pour nous engager
avec tout ça pour résister au péché de
gourmandise il faut vraiment avoir de
l'estomac
justement demain au lever du soleil
il y aura un milliard d'estomac en train
de jeûner
comme chaque jour on termine avec